i was a bit reluctant in um joining the
project
i've had a few invitations to other
projects uh of the same subject before
and i just you know uh denied my
participation to all of them
took a while of convincing just simply
because you know of the
of the subject matter that it's not such
a
nice thing that happened and the fact
that i was involved in it
this guy morbid must have killed elisa
lamb
he was staying at the hotel she was a
sitting duck and was
easily manipulated by this perp punk
everyone suspects him
i think that was actually the main
reason why i
had to double think it you know because
i knew the exposure this got in the past
with just a few people in the internet
just doing this
you know and just went so spread like
wildfire just
went out of control so i thought you
know
uh this is going to be like
bigger exposure about this subject so
i'm just i'm still
just scr um i'm still like just crossing
my fingers that
it won't get too wild i stay there it
was
probably february 2012. uh traveled from
the east coast i was in cincinnati
recording my album
and my time there just expired and i
just you know
needed to do i needed to change my life
you know i decided to move to la and you
know
i just stayed there for three days while
i was uh talking to
two friends over there and then after
that you know i stayed with friends
did my thing so just those three days
was like enough to like
completely change my life which is a
strange thing you know
morbid has always been me
my my dark soul subconscious
i do horror music i i do horror
screenplays
so i'm i'm pretty aware of like you know
who richard mirris is or charles madison
or whatever
so if only i knew that he was staying
there you know my
my my stay there would have been
different because i you know i would
have
known that that place had some sore
sort of dark history in it
and i will probably be more precautious
yeah i mean originally
i had a my band so you know when this
happened
i actually joked a little bit around
around it with my
drummer because you know we didn't know
that it was going to
get this out of control you know we just
thought all right someone in the
internet wrote something you know
so we're just joking and uh so yeah you
know
originally i just didn't mind it that
much i was like all right yeah
cool you know some strange rumors or
whatever
but then you know as this went by and
you know as i started
losing my my accounts and
watched my whole world kind of started
crumbling
when you see your name and your picture
and your video on the tv news station in
another country
and you don't even know what it says
because it's a different language but
then someone tells you they translated
it and it says that you're a suspect
killer
you're like whoa i mean this is not good
it was serious stuff
and you know and and then you know you
start losing you start losing everything
that you have and you can't really
defend yourself because
who is the people doing this like
i mean i reach out some people and i you
know try to reason with them
and i was like hey you know you should
stop this
my friends my friends were supportive
and they still are some of them actually
they still
talk about those times and they you know
they were there
and uh yeah you know everyone you know
their my name was in forums
uh just it just expanded like wildfire
just like
you know in a matter of days so my
friends sometimes they went to forums
and they
tried to clear my name you know and they
were like hey man i know this dude he's
not a killer
he's not a bad guy you know he's she
just makes horror music like
that's that's it and but you know it
didn't help at all you know yeah
they made facebook groups and like i
said forums everywhere
they will get into my accounts and steal
my
my media pictures video everything posts
and then just twist them and you know
use them against me
i'm getting a lot of messages from
people and
yeah just a lot of positive response
just a lot of
you know just a lot of love from people
and um
the best part is just having kids that
have told me that
they are going through issues that are
like
the one i went to and uh you know that
they were cyber bullied or they
had issues with depression and they are
reaching out and i'm you know talking to
them and just kind of
trying to be a guide somehow you know
because uh i mean
what i experienced where i survived was
heavy
it's just when something is happening to
you like you really don't have any
guidelines
you don't know really what to do so
you know i what i did was just bury
myself in work and just
yeah try to forget about it leaving
denial but i
realized it was there all the time and
when i saw it
uh when i saw the docu and my chapter
it takes a different stand when you look
for
when you look at it from the distance
you know because i
i had it in my world all the time but
when i see it from the outside i'm like
geez it's like yeah that's not no one
should go to that you know it's like
and lucky for me i survived it and it
wasn't easy
i'm still scarred as you can imagine but
yeah this is something that you know we
really need to
grow some consciousness about i really
don't have a conclusion of my own of
like what i think about
what happened and
i think there's always going to be that
like mystery that like
there's something wrong and especially
when it comes from that place you know
like
when you're you know it's not that it
happened somewhere else it just happened
in the season
and that's you know that that in itself
is just you know tapes way to
you know maybe think that there's
something